welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today we are discussing tools
for mood and mental health I will
include tools and resources taken from
the guest episode that I did with Dr
Lisa Feldman Barrett who is a
psychologist and neuroscientist whose
laboratory focuses on mood and emotion
during that episode she mentioned
several important tools that I do
believe everybody should apply and that
indeed I've been applying to my own life
and have found to be extremely
beneficial I will also highlight some of
the specific research articles those
tools are based on which were not
covered in the podcast with Lisa I will
also discuss tools glean from the four
episode series that I did on Mental
Health with Dr Paul kti who is a medical
doctor specializing in Psychiatry and
that episode as some of you may already
know focused on mental health and the
self as well as relationships and it
included a deep discussion of what is
the self we talked about the unconscious
mind and the conscious mind and we also
covered a lot of tools for understanding
oneself both within the context of
therapy but also within the context of
things that one can do alone and that
require zero cost in addition we talked
about tools for improving relationships
we talked about first principles of
self-care so I will provide highlights
and takeaways of those tools during
today's episode and thirdly I will
include tools what we often refer to as
protocols gleaned from some recent
Publications indeed Publications that
came out as recently as two weeks ago
which really emphasize specific things
that we can all do that again are zero
cost that have been shown in quality
peer-reviewed research to significantly
improve mood and mental health for
instance if you're a regular listener of
this podcast you are probably familiar
with my nearly constant reminder that
people should view morning sunlight and
afternoon sunlight and if you can't to
embrace some Alternatives like looking
at bright artificial light although
sunlight is best well there was a recent
paper published in the journal Nature
mental health an excellent Journal
focusing on not just the positive
effects of viewing light at those times
of day and indeed throughout the day but
also the independent and positive
effects of being in darkness for 6 to 8
hours every night that's right not only
is light during the day correlated with
significantly improved mental health
outcomes but Darkness at night that is
avoiding lights not just bright lights
but lights for up to eight hours at
certain periods of your 24-hour
circadian cycle has been correlated with
improved mental health outcomes and
indeed has been shown to significantly
offset certain negative mental health
outcomes this is a spectacular study
again it involved a enormous number of
research subjects more than 85,000
research subjects and it touches on a
large number of actionable protocols
that I've distilled down to just one or
two things that all of us can easily do
to improve our mood and mental health on
a consistent basis before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Plunge
plunge makes what I believe is the most
versatile at home self-cooling cold
plunge for deliberate cold exposure I've
covered the topic of deliberate cold
exposure several times on this podcast
indeed we did an entire episode about
deliberate cold exposure and what's very
clear from the research literature is
that deliberate cold exposure can induce
dramatic positive shifts in so-called
catac colomines that is dopamine
norepinephrine and epinephrine this is a
small collection of molecules that are
released in the brain and body body when
we do deliberate cold exposure and that
subjectively lead to greatly enhanced
feelings of mood alertness and focus for
many hours afterwards that's perhaps the
best substantiated reason and the most
popular reason why people who get into
deliberate cold exposure no pun intended
continue to do deliberate cold exposure
on a consistent basis plunge uses a
powerful and very easy to use cooling
filtration and sanitation unit to give
you access to deliberate cold exposure
in clean water whenever you want I've
used a plunge for several years now and
I really like it because first of all it
can use a standard outlet you don't have
to modify the electricity in your home
or yard and it's very easy to clean in
fact it stays clean for long periods of
time which makes it very easy to
maintain as well plunge has several
different models to select from
including their new all-in cold plunge
which offers faster cooling smartphone
connectivity and more if you're
interested in getting a plunge you can
go to plunge spelled p l u n
g.com huberman to to get $150 off your
cold plunge again that's plunge. comom
huberman to get $150 off today's episode
is also brought To Us by eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart mattress covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
in this podcast about the fact that
sleep that is getting enough quality
sleep on a consistent basis is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance now one of the
key things to getting the best possible
night sleep is to control the
temperature of your sleeping environment
and that's because in order to fall and
stay deeply asleep your body temperature
needs to drop by about 1 to 3° and in
order to wake up feeling refreshed and
energized your body temperature actually
has to increase by about 1 to 3° with
eight sleep controlling the temperature
of your sleeping environment is made
extremely easy eight Sleep mattress
covers allow you to program the
temperature of your sleeping environment
at the beginning middle and end of your
night it can even divide the temperature
on the two sides of the bed for
different people it also has sleep
tracking capacity it will tell you how
much slow wave sleep and rapid eye
movement sleep you're getting and really
help you you dial in the exact
parameters so you can get the best
possible night sleep I've been sleeping
on an eight sleep mattress cover for
well over 2 years now and it has
significantly improved my sleep and
therefore my daytime mood focus and
alertness if you'd like to try eight
sleep you can go to eights sleep.com
huberman and save up to $150 off their
pod three covers eight sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's 8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by waking up waking up is a
meditation app that includes hundreds of
meditation programs mindfulness
trainings yoga NRA sessions and nsdr
non-sleep deep rest protocols I started
using the waking up app a few years ago
because even though I've been doing
regular meditation since my teens and I
started doing Yoga Nidra about a decade
ago my dad mentioned to me that he had
found an app turned out to be the waking
up app which could teach you meditations
of different durations and that had a
lot of different types of meditations to
play place the brain and body into
different states and that he liked it
very much so I gave the waking up app a
try and I too found it to be extremely
useful because sometimes I only have a
few minutes to meditate other times I
have longer to meditate and indeed I
love the fact that I can explore
different types of meditation to bring
about different levels of understanding
about Consciousness but also to place my
brain and body into lots of different
kinds of States depending on which
meditation I do I also love that the
waking up app has lots of different
types of Yoga Nidra sessions for those
of you don't know Yoga Nidra is a
process of lying very still but keeping
an active mind it's very different than
most meditations and there's excellent
scientific data to show that yoganidra
and something similar to it called
non-sleep deep rest or nstr can greatly
restore levels of cognitive and physical
energy even with just a short 10minute
session if you'd like to try the waking
up app you can go to waking up.com
huberman and access a free 30-day trial
again that's waking up.com huberman to
access a free 30-day trial okay let's
talk about tools for improving mood and
mental health I think it goes without
saying that these are extremely
important topics for everyone not just
to know about but in my opinion also for
people to implement and the reason is
that we are currently in a worldwide
Mental Health crisis and while we could
debate the reason why we are in a
worldwide Mental Health crisis it's very
very clear that mood disorders and
challenges with mental health about
found and of course there are many
different therapies for the treatment of
mood disorders and mental health
everything from talk therapy with a
psychologist or psychiatrist or social
worker prescription drug treatments
there nutritional approaches sematic
approaches and I want to be clear that I
do believe that there's value in all of
these approaches what tends to matter in
terms of what sorts of tools and
approaches one adopts includes both
access so whether or not people have
access to these type of therapies
whether or not they can afford them on a
consistent basis and also of course the
severity of the mood or mental health
disorder and I'd be remiss of course if
I didn't make the statement and I don't
say this just to protect me I also say
this to protect all of you and those
that you know that if you are concerned
about yourself or somebody else having a
serious mood or mental health disorder
please do seek out help from a licensed
clinical psychologist or psychiatrist or
other healthc care professional who's
qualified to help you in that regard
with that said we can now have a
discussion about tools and protocols for
enhancing mood and mental health that
truly appli to everybody regardless of
age to start off I want to talk about a
fundamental aspect of mood and mental
health enhancement that was discussed
both in the guest episode with Dr Lisa
Feldman Barrett as well as in the guest
series with Dr Paul Ki and that has to
do with what Dr Paul Ki referred to as
the first principles of self-care or
mental health the first principles of
self-care include but are not limited to
taking excellent care of one's biology
which of course includes both the mind
and the body and in order to make this
very simple and actionable I've
distilled out what I refer to as the big
six I've sometimes refer to these as the
six major pillars of Health both mental
health and physical health as well as
performance for that matter but if we're
going to talk about tools for mood and
mental health we absolutely can't
discard discussions about our biology
that is we need to make sure that we're
taking care of our normal biological
function and indeed enhancing the
production of specific neurotransmitters
and neuromodulators that we are
optimizing yes I use the word optimizing
the function of our so-called autonomic
nervous system that aspect of our
nervous system that's humming in the
background all the time it's operating
unconsciously to regulate our sleep wake
Cycles it's regulating how well or
poorly we react to things it's
regulating how much dopamine serotonin
epinephrine acetylcholine we were
producing all of this stuff is humming
in the background and sets the stage for
all the conscious work that we might put
to for instance trying to understand
what our life narrative is what our
unconscious mind is doing what sorts of
defenses it might producing all of the
sort of high level and directed work
that we're going to talk about a little
bit later exists on a background of
autonomic function of neurotransmitter
production of hormone production not
just testosterone and estrogen but
things like cortisol prolactin and on
and on so it's important to understand
that if our goal is to be in the best
possible mood given our life
circumstances and to have the best
possible mental health given our life
circumstances and to improve our mood
and mental health consistently over time
that we have to pay attention to what
I'm referring to here as the big six or
the six pillars of mental health and
those are just to list them off then
I'll go into a little bit more detail
sleep Sun sunlight although I'd like to
modify sunlight because based on some
new data that just came out a couple of
weeks ago I'd like to now make that
second pillar not sunlight but light SL
dark so we could even just think about
it as light when and how much light you
get but what you'll soon learn is that
how much dark you get is also extremely
important so we've got sleep light
movement is the third nutrition social
connection and Stress Control now these
are topics that I've spoken about
extensively on previous huin Lab podcast
episodes so I don't want to go into a
deep dive of each of these six pillars
right now but I am going to just give
you a few highlights of each and then of
course we will provide links in the show
note captions for which you can go on
the Deep dive if you like and I also
would like to mention that if you ever
have questions about specific protocols
or tools and you're seeking those out or
previous episodes or specific timestamps
of previous episodes of this podcast you
can go to our newly revamped hubman
lab.com webbsite and put any topic of
Interest or even several topics of
Interest into the search function and it
will take you to the very specific
timestamps and other resources that
provide information on those topics so
I'm going to go into a few of the key
bullet points about each of the six
pillars or what I also refer to as the
big six of self-care and mental health
again this is a necessary list but is
not sufficient again necessary to do
these things every 24 hours hours indeed
every 24 hours if you want to have the
best possible mood and mental health but
it is not sufficient that means you
still need to do some of the other
things that we're going to talk about in
terms of directed approaches at
improving mood and mental health if you
are to quote unquote optimize your mood
and mental health or if you are let's
just say trying to constantly improve
your mood and mental health but these
are the necessary but not sufficient
pillars of mental health so Under The
Heading of sleep it's safe to say that
most people need between 6 to 8 hours of
sleep per night some people can get away
with five some people need as much as
nine or 10 certainly Growing Kids babies
teenagers and those that are suffering
from some sort of illness are going to
need more as much as 9 10 maybe even 12
hours of sleep per night however most
people do well to get somewhere between
six and8 hours of sleep per night you're
just going to have to experiment and
figure out what's best for you now one
thing I heard recently so I can't claim
this as an original idea but that I
think is a really good way to think
about sleep is that sleep much like
physical fitness is something that we
have to constantly be working on it's
not the sort of thing where you can get
a great night's sleep one night and then
the next night just kind of let all the
protocols go and expect to get a great
night's sleep you don't have to be
neurotic about getting a great night's
sleep indeed I do believe that we should
strive to get enough quality sleep as
many of the nights of our life as
possible and if you can't do do that
hopefully it's for good reasons but of
course things happen in life raising
kids you have emergencies all nighters
to study so you can make sure you get
that best possible grade on exam etc etc
but we should all strive to get the best
quality sleep that we can and as much of
it most nights of our lives so it's
important to look at sleep as a process
that you're going to be working on for
the rest of your life just like Fitness
and I don't say that to overwhelm you I
say that so that if On Any Given night
you get a poor night's sleep you don't
stress that too much you just get back
on the wagon and you try and get the
best possible night sleep the next night
and the next night and the next night
much like Fitness there's no 10-week
program that's going to transform your
physical fitness forever okay just like
there's no sleep program that's going to
transform your sleep forever it's a
daily or rather I should say nightly
investment although some of the things
that are going to positively impact your
sleep or perhaps damage your sleep are
things that you do during the daytime
right so avoid that caffeine too late in
the day get that morning sunlight and on
and on but if you sleep sleep is
something that you're constantly
investing in and it is a critical
investment for your mood and mental
health the other thing that's not often
discussed and I really haven't talked
about terribly much on this podcast is
the importance of having a fairly
consistent sleep routine now I realize
that not everybody can get to sleep at
the exact same time each night and wake
up at the exact same time each morning
and frankly that's not practical I
certainly don't do that however what we
know from the Circadian Health
literature is that everybody strive
again that strive nobody's perfect but
strive to get to sleep at more or less
the same time each night and wake up at
more or less the same time each morning
this turns out to be really important
for regulating mood and mental health
and indeed for improving your overall
levels of sleep getting the optimal
amounts of slow wave sleep AK deep sleep
and rapid eye movement sleep and what we
know is that ideally you're going to get
to sleep within plus or minus 1 hour of
your regular sleep time so if your
regular to bed time is 10:00 you're used
to getting in bed at 10:00 and falling
asleep somewhere around 10:30 well then
if the next night you fall asleep at
9:30 great you're still within the plus
or minus one hour and if the next night
you go to sleep and you don't fall
asleep till 11:30 don't sweat it in fact
you're still within that plus or minus
one hour however if you start getting
into a habit of going to bed at vastly
different times deviating more than or
less than one hour from your normal to
bedtime well then you're going to start
to run into issues such as as waking up
feeling groggy even if you got enough
sleep so even if you slept the full
eight hours that you're used to getting
people who go to sleep much later than
they normally do or much earlier than
they normally do start getting into kind
of issues of mood regulation energy
regulation not just in the morning but
in the afternoon likewise try and wake
up at more or less the same time each
morning plus or minus one hour that's
really going to help you anchor your
overall sleep schedule and it's really
going to help lead to predictability of
your overall levels of energy mood and
focus throughout the day the second
pillar in that big six is light and I
used to refer to this as sunlight right
I'd say and I'm going to say it again
now although I've covered this in a lot
more detail so again just hitting the
top Contour critical
elements try to view sunlight that is
with your eyes view sunlight as early as
possible after waking whenever I say
that the most common question I get is
what do I do if I wake up before the sun
comes out well unless you have
superpowers that I'm not aware of you
can't make the sun come out any earlier
so just flip on artificial lights as
needed until the sun comes out and then
get outside face East in the morning
take off those sunglasses it's perfectly
safe to look at low solar angle sunlight
without sunglasses providing you're not
you know driving into bright light and
you crash this kind of thing get outside
look at the sunlight definitely blink to
protect your eyes as needed but get that
sunlight in your eyes early in the day
this has Myriad positive effects on mood
focus and alertness and nighttime sleep
later that night and it does so through
a number of well-defined biological and
endocrine hormonal Pathways that I've
discussed on many previous podcast
episodes and you want to do this for
about 10 minutes on non- overcast days
and as long as 20 or 30 minutes on
overcast days and that highlights the
second most common question I get which
is what do I do if there's no sun where
I live I live in an area where there's
no sunlight look if you live on planet
Earth there's always sunlight there
might not be very much of it it might be
very overcast where you live it might
seem very dark but trust me there's far
more photons light energy coming through
that cloud cover even in the darkest
mornings of winter than there are at
night in those dark Winters so get that
light in your eyes and do it as
consistently as possible and also do
that in the late afternoon and evening
that's critical for regulating your
circadian clock for reasons that I've
talked about previously but I'll get
into in a future podcast really
explaining how those clock oscillators
and mechanisms work but just to keep it
really simple since this this is a
toolkit episode for mood and mental
health your mood and your mental health
will benefit tremendously from getting
morning sunlight in your eyes now if you
need to get more light in your eyes
because indeed there's just not enough
sunlight or you don't have the
opportunity to get outside and view
sunlight in the morning for whatever
reason you might invest in getting a
bright light source that you can plug in
you probably want one that's as bright
as 10,000 lucks so that's pretty bright
those fall under the category of
so-called sad lamps sad Seasonal
effective disorder lamps and you can
purchase those they can be somewhat
expensive you can also opt to get a 900
Lu drawing tablet by the way I have no
Financial relationship to any of these
sorts of light sources but you can find
them pretty easily and in the case of
the 900 Lux light tablet um fairly
inexpensively online and you can put
that on your desk or where you have your
morning coffee and try and enhance the
total amount of light that you're
getting in the morning but frankly
nothing is as good as sunlight so if you
can't get sunlight you might think about
investing in one of those sad lamps and
indeed those sad lamps aren't as good as
sunlight but they are the next best
thing if you really can't get sunlight
on a consistent basis a few other fine
points that I always get asked about
first of all it is absolutely okay to
wear eyeglasses or contact lenses those
sorts of corrective lenses are actually
going to focus the light to your retina
which is where you want it however this
whole process of viewing morning
sunlight and afternoon light does not
again does not work through a window or
windshield because windows and
windshields filter out the relevant
wavelengths of light that you want to
get directly onto your retina okay so
that's the reality of it in addition
please don't feel that you have to look
directly at the Sun and certainly don't
stare at the Sun never force yourself to
look at any light sunlight or otherwise
that's so bright that it's painful to
look at so if it's comfortable for you
to look directly at the Sun and just
blink every once in a while and you can
do that without any pain or discomfort
or watering of the eyes please do that
you're getting a lot of photons into
your eyes and they're transmitting that
to your brein brain and your brain to
the rest of your body and on and on
however if you find it uncomfortable to
look directly at the sun in that case
what you'll want to do is offset your
gaze to you know 10 or 20 degrees which
is nerd speak for just a little bit to
the right or a little bit to the left
and get the sunlight into your eyes
indirectly okay and I often also get
asked well can I stand in the shade
while I do this what if I have an
overhang in my apartment the best thing
is of course going to be to face
directly to the Sun and look either
directly at it or slightly offset but if
you can only get morning sunlight by
going out onto your balcony and your
balcony doesn't face East rather it
faces West you'll still get a lot of
photons from the Sun Reaching Your Eyes
there but ideally you would find some
way to look toward the sun first thing
in the morning I realize that with kids
and work and other obligations this can
be challenging but it is a challenge
worth meeting meaning don't lose your
job or forget to take care of your kids
to do this but you can bring your kids
to do this and indeed you should it sets
their circadian rhythms also so and
people often will ask well does it work
on dogs you know and indeed dogs and
other animals have these exact same
circuits and Pathways for setting their
circadian rhythm so it's great for them
too now there are also clear and
documented benefits for mood and mental
health to getting bright light in your
eyes ideally from sunlight throughout
the day as much as you safely can please
don't get sunburned don't get cataracts
by getting too much sunlight but getting
outdoors and getting sunlight in your
eyes during your lunch break or a walk
here and there or if you have to remain
indoors during the day getting the
lights in that environment as bright as
possible as safely possible I should say
is known to improve mood and mental
health why well because there's a
special so-called opsin within the cells
of your eyes it's called melanopsin that
doesn't respond to the same differences
in color that are present in sunlight in
the morning and the evening but rather
responds to the overall brightness of
light so very bright lights either from
artificial sources or ideally from
sunlight activate these cells and these
cells project these little wires we call
axons into specific parts of the brain
that improve your mood and feelings of
well-being so I can't give you a
specific number you know of five minutes
a day or 10 minutes a day just get as
much light in your eyes ideally from
sunlight throughout the day as is safe
for you meaning where you're not getting
sunburned and you're not damaging your
retina and if you want to know if you're
damaging your retina well anytime you
have to Blink or turn away from light
because it's really bright that's a
signal that the light is too bright so
while you want to place yourself into
bright environments you don't want to
place yourself into any environment so
bright that it's painful to be in okay
so use that as a metric and you should
be just fine and the last point about
light for mood and mental health is a
relatively recent theme that's emerging
from the scientific literature and that
really was driven home by a recent study
that I mentioned a little bit earlier in
the episode this is the study publish in
nature mental health showing that
Darkness during a particular stage of
your 24-hour cycle your so-called
circadian rhythm is also very beneficial
for mood and mental health and it's
beneficial for mood and mental health in
a way that is independent from light and
from sleep now what do I mean by that
okay well there are a number of
different ways that this can be examined
but in this particular study which I
like oh so much entitled day and night
light exposure are associated with
psychiatric disorders an objective light
study in more than 85,000 people what
the researchers did is they analyzed how
much light and or dark people were
getting across the 24-hour cycle and
correlated that with mental health
outcomes looking at a range of different
mental health challenges including
bipolar disorder schizophrenia
depression PTSD and much more and I'll
go into this study in a lot of detail in
a future episode because it's such an
important study with so many gems
withinin it that we should all know
about but one of the key things from
this study is that the positive effects
of daytime sunlight exposure and the
positive effects of nighttime dark
exposure that means of course the
absence of light are independent of one
another put differently making sure that
you are in very dim to completely dark
environments for a continuous 6 to8
hours within every 24-hour circadian
cycle is correlated with much better
mental health outcomes in other words we
shouldn't just think about the presence
of light in the morning and throughout
the day as positive for mental health
that's all true it's absolutely true and
this study further verifies that but
that's been known for some time indeed
decades from the scientific research and
of course it's been known for thousands
of years intuitively and subjectively
without detailed scientific
measurement but in addition to that this
study shows that people who stay in very
dim to dark environments for eight hours
every 24 hours or I should say
approximately eight hours in every
24-hour cycle they benefit from improved
mood and mental health outcomes in a way
that's independent of how much light
they're getting and independent of how
much sleep they are getting the point is
this the time when you wake up consider
that time zero and then about again you
don't have to be super strict about this
about 16 to 24 hours after that wakeup
time you should be in a very dim to dark
environment for that 16-hour to 24-Hour
period after wake up okay what do I mean
by this I mean if you go to sleep at 10:
p.m. and you wake up at 6:00 a.m. well
that 10: p.m. to 6:00 a.m. phase of your
circadian cycle you should be in very
dim light or entirely dark environment
this is a great opportunity to reference
another study which is published in the
proceeds of the National Academy of
Sciences which shows that even having a
small amount of light in the room which
isn't even that bright while you're
sleeping with eyes closed can disrupt
morning glucose levels so in other words
keep your sleeping environment dark keep
your nighttime environment dim to the
best of your abilities right certainly
go out to dinner every once in a while
go to the movies go out and have a party
enjoy yourself if you have to go to the
hospital God forbid or you have to tend
to some emergency do that but to the
extent that you can control it within
the confines of life and its demands
keep your nighttime environment dim or
dark because that independently of any
sunlight and other bright light that
you're viewing during the daytime and
afternoon is going to positively improve
your mood and mental health now moving
on to the other pillars and these I'm
going to move through a bit more quickly
than I have the previous two because
we've done entire series on these or I
should say serieses serieses is that how
you pronounce it someone put the plural
of serieses in the show in the comments
on YouTube the third pillar is movement
and when I say movement I mean exercise
as you all know we should all strive to
get anywhere from 180 to 220 minutes of
Zone 2 cardio per week that's movement
that allows you to hold a conversation
but where you to do it more intensely or
even a bit more intensely you wouldn't
be able to hold that conversation in
addition we should do some V2 Max work
we should get our heart rate very high
at least once a week doing some sort of
movement that's safe for you so that
could be running or cycling or swimming
or Pilates whatever it is for you
getting your heart rate way way up is
also important and to do that at least
once a week but daily movement either
cardiovascular training or resistance
training and it's very very clear that
we need both maybe not on the same days
in fact I split them to separate days
resistance training done for anywhere
from six to 10 sets per muscle group
either close to or to failure this could
be with weights it could be with bands
it could be with machines all of that
was covered in detail in the podcast
series that I did with Dr Andy Galpin an
exercise physiologist who's expert in
all those areas I also did an episode on
a foundational Fitness protocol that has
been distilled into a very simple
three-page PDF that you can get for
completely zero cost by going to hu
lab.com and just put foundational
Fitness protocol PDF and you'll be taken
to that toolkit so all of the details of
a weekly exercise routine that involves
daily movement but also certainly in my
case includes at least one full day of
rest per week because many people do
indeed need one maybe even two full days
of rest per week so that highlights the
third pillar movement but we know that
cardiovascular training and resistance
training aren't just great for our body
they also improve mood and mental health
that's so very clear from the research
literature so we can't Overlook those in
a conversation about mood and mental
health now the fourth pillar is
nutrition and nutrition is a big topic
it's a very barbed wire topic if you get
involved in this stuff online you know
you you've got your people who believe
that you know carnivore is better than
vegan you have the people who believe
vegan is better than carnivore most
people are omnivores you have your seed
oil debates and on and on and on we're
not going to touch any of that now
indeed if you want to learn more about
nutrition and what works and what
doesn't work for sake of aesthetic
changes weight loss muscle gain Etc I
would refer you to the guest episode
that we did with Dr Lane Norton you can
find that again at huberman lab.com
where we do a deep dive on all the
variations in different nutritional
protocols but suffice to say that
regardless of whether or not you're
vegan omnivore carnivore or keto or
whatever everybody needs to consume
sufficient amounts but not excess
amounts of quality calories per day now
you may do that by intermittent fasting
you may do that by a more traditional
meal scheduling but everybody's going to
need to do that because your body and
brain and indeed the parts of your body
and brain that translate to mood and
mental health require macronutrients
proteins fats and carbohydrates as well
as micronutrients so the key takeaway
with nutrition is to make it quality
nutrition within the bounds of whatever
sort of nutritional program that you're
following and that means getting most of
your food sources from either
nonprocessed or minimally processed
foods so these would be foods that
you're going to need to prepare or foods
that would perish um over time these are
not the sorts of foods that live in
boxes and cans and other uh packages
that would allow them to live on the
shelves forever and ever okay and as I
say that I know many people are shouting
well what about rice you know rice can
live on the shelf for a long time and
yes okay I consider rice a minimally
processed food because of course it can
live on the shelf for a long period of
time and here I'm just going to back out
of the whole conversation about
nutrition at this point because as you
can probably tell it's a deep series of
rabbit holes that we can fall into and
really get distracted the point is make
sure you're getting enough food don't
overeat we know energy toxicity is a
problem for not just body composition
but for mental health so you want to get
enough calories but not too few calories
and you want to make sure that you're
getting them from quality sources and I
say that because of course food is not
just the substrate for the cellular
repair and indeed production of tissues
in your body but it's also the substrate
for all the sorts of neurotransmitters
right which are derived from amino acid
precursors that are derived from food
right all of that dopamine stuff and
serotonin stuff is derived from amino
acids that come from food sources so the
link between nutrition and mental health
should now be an obvious one as we all
know quality nutrition influences of
course our physical health but also our
mental health and our cognitive
functioning our memory our ability to
learn new things and to focus and we
know that one of the most important
features of highquality nutrition is
making sure that we get enough vitamins
and minerals from high quality
unprocessed or minimally processed
sources as well as enough probiotics and
prebiotics and fiber to support
basically all the cellular functions in
our body including the gut microbiome
now I like most everybody try to get
optimal nutrition from Whole Foods
ideally mostly from minimally processed
or non-processed Foods however one of
the challenges that I and so many other
people face is getting enough servings
of high quality fruits and vegetables
per day as well as fiber and probiotics
that often accompany those fruits and
vegetables that's why way back in 2012
long before I ever had a podcast I
started drinking ag1 and so I'm
delighted that ag1 is sponsoring the
huberman Lab podcast the reason I
started taking ag1 and the reason I
still drink ag1 once or twice a day is
that it provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com huberman to claim a special
offer they're giving away five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
huberman to claim that special offer the
fifth pillar in the big six is social
connection and we're going to talk a
little bit more about this later in the
episode but let's let's just be very
brief and specific about this we all
need to strive to limit the number of
social interactions that we feel tax or
even Vex us that cause us stress this is
something that was covered in depth in
the episode with Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett
where she talked about the fact that we
don't just have a nervous system that
regulates itself through experience and
through our thoughts and our actions we
are as a species interacting with other
nervous systems both of our own species
other humans as well as non-human
species dogs and cats and if you have
them horses and other animals so we need
to think about our nervous system as
being both regulated from the inside and
through our own actions and choices and
thoughts but also through interaction
with other nervous systems and while we
don't always have as much control over
Which social interactions or work
interactions we have to engage in we
should really strive to understand and
indeed pay some serious attention to
whether or not certain types of social
interactions
are what she referred to as net savings
neutral or taxing right certain types of
social interactions with certain people
or groups of people just make us feel
taxed it makes us feel stressed it leads
to negative affect that is not good
feelings or emotions and often elevated
levels of autonomic arousal that leave
us ruminating and leave us having
challenges with sleep we really should
all strive to limit those interactions
to the extent that we can on the reverse
side of that as Lisa Felman Barrett so
beautifully pointed out we also have the
capability to regulate each other's
nervous systems in ways that produce
savings that is that allow us to feel
and indeed cause physiological changes
that make us feel not just happier not
just relaxed not just happy because we
enjoy interacting with somebody but or a
group but that give us a savings that
give us the kind of resources literally
metabolic and neurochemical resources
that make us feel more capable and give
us a sense of elevated mood and improved
mental health when we are not engaging
with those people and this is highly
subjective of course but you should be
able to distinguish in fact I encourage
you to spend a little bit of time maybe
even just five or 10 minutes thinking
about you know who are the individuals
and groups that I interact with that
leave me feeling taxed you know that
really seem to drain my energy and have
me ruminating and in a not good space
when I leave whatever interaction I had
with them this could be a real
interaction or online interaction indeed
I did this the other day based on Lisa's
suggestion I found it to be tremendously
useful what I did is I decided to and by
the way this was happening on a run
where I was thinking you know a lot of
my mind is in a conversation with people
that aren't even here I was sort of
working through a conversation I was
thinking about what I would say what I
did say what they said in an interaction
that unfortunately was pretty unpleasant
it wasn't extremely unpleasant but it
was pretty unpleasant and I realized
okay that that is a sort of interaction
that I would like to avoid in the future
because it wasn't happening right then
but it was carried forward into a
portion of my day my morning run that
for me is normally very pleasureful and
quite sacred to me actually so paying
some attention to how much of your
internal dialogue is with yourself
versus with others and how much of that
is positive or negative is extremely
beneficial and I'm not talking about
always just thinking about oneself and
not thinking about others to the
contrary we also need to think as Lisa
pointed out about who are the people
with whom we interact with or observe
that lead us to have ongoing dialogue
with them in our mind or think about
those interactions in ways that give us
energy that lead to energetic savings
literally metabolic savings that we can
apply not just in those interactions but
in our work Endeavors and our solo
Endeavors whatever that we're doing when
we are away from those people so while
this concept of savings or neutral or
taxation of our metabolic and our
neurochemical systems might seem a
little bit squishy it is not squishy
this is a neurobiological concept it's
also a psychological concept and it's
one that I'm so glad that Lisa brought
up because social connection social
interaction is so vital to our mood and
mental health but oftentimes we hear
social connection we think oh that means
we have to spend a lot of time with
friends we have to organize dinner
parties well sure that's all fine and
good if you can do that and I do of
course encourage people to spend time
with those that they love but it's also
important to take a step back and just
think a bit maybe even write out a bit
you know who are the groups and sorts of
individuals and interactions that really
tax you who are the people you find kind
of neutral and what are the individuals
and groups that really provide what Lisa
referred to as savings that is they tap
into the metabolic and neurochemical
Pathways that lead us to have improved
mood and mental health not just during
those interactions but away from those
interactions as well and often
pervasively and extremely positively so
so it this is no small de
this is a really important aspect of our
mental health now the sixth pillar in
the big six is stress control and the
reason it's included is that look stress
is going to happen life is filled with
so-called stressors and for a good
number of years in fact the last 15
years there's been a lot of debate in
the field of Psychology and Neuroscience
as well whether or not stress is good
for us whether or not stress is bad for
us whether or not we simply need to
reframe stress as good or bad and to
some extent all of that is true you know
we know that chronic stress is not good
for our memory our immune system or our
health we also know that if you
understand the reality which is that
stress also allows us to harness our
mental and physical resources to perform
better than we would otherwise in
certain circumstances and that provided
we can get to sleep each night that
perhaps stress isn't so bad and perhaps
is even performance enhancing I talked
about this in the guest episode with Dr
Ali Crumb from the psychology department
at Stanford and I've talked about this
in other podcasts as well and I'm not
here to tell you that stress is good for
you I'm not here to tell you that stress
is bad for you what I am going to tell
you is that it is extremely important
that we all have readily accessible
Stress Management tools that work the
first time and every time and these fall
into two categories the first category
are realtime tools so tools that you can
use to reduce your level of stress in
real time and the best way that I'm
aware of that's grounded in excellent
physiology and Neuroscience to reduce
your stress in real time is the
so-called physiological side I did not
invent this pattern of breathing it's
not breath work per se this is a pattern
of breathing that we all naturally do in
our sleep to restore carbon dioxide and
oxygen levels to their proper ratios we
also do it periodically throughout the
day without noticing indeed we have a
defined or specific neural circuit in
our brain that extends to our diaphragm
and communicates with aspects of our
heart Etc that allow physiological size
to calm us down faster at least in my
knowledge than any other directed
protocol and the physiological sigh as
many of you know is very simple and
straightforward anyone can do this you
simply do a big inhale through your nose
try and maximize the inflation of your
lungs and then before you exhale sneak
in another brief inhalation even if it's
just a tiny micro inhalation to
maximally inflate the lungs and that has
an important effect on the little Sachs
in the lungs called the avioli of the
lungs it's going to open up whatever
avioli we collapsed in there and then
you're going to do a long extended
exhale through the mouth and typically
just one although sometimes it requires
two or three but just one physiological
sigh is effective in bringing down one's
level of stress significantly enough
that you don't need to do it again so
this can be done essentially anywhere
and by anyone I suppose probably
couldn't do it if you were underwater or
certainly don't do it if you're
underwater but otherwise it's a very
safe and very effective way to calm down
and reduce your levels of stress in real
time maybe before public speaking or in
whatever circumstance you feel you need
to calm down in real time so I'll
demonstrate the physiological side for
you here I've done this many times
before in previous episodes but for
those of you that haven't heard or seen
those episodes I feel obligated to do it
again now okay so it's a deep inhale
through the nose followed by another
brief inhale through the nose and then a
long exhale through the mouth and before
you start asking questions about what do
I do if I have a deviated septum can it
be just through the mouth do the first
two through the nose do the third
through the mouth so it's like
this and indeed I feel calmer and indeed
if you do it you will feel calmer you'll
notice that second inhale through the
nose was kind of sharp in the sense that
I had to really push um put some
physical effort into making it happen
and you know my shoulders jolted upwards
if you just listening to this and not
watching my shoulders jolted upwards
that second inhale through the nose is
important for a variety of reasons I've
talked about elsewhere so the
physiological sigh is going to be the
go-to protocol for you again not
invented by me this is not huberman
breathing this is a pattern of breathing
discovered in the 1930s by physiologists
it's hardwired into our nervous system
and that's what makes it so great it
works the first time and it works every
time so that's to my knowledge the best
way to control your stress in real time
now why is that important for mood and
mental health well as we'll talk about
later
if you want to access your so-called
generative drive a theme that we're
going to get into in a bit more detail
this is something that came up during
the series with Dr Paul kti you will
learn that stress and anger and negative
emotions while they can be very
motivating very arousing they are not
going to be good for your long-term mood
and mental health period so having tools
to regulate your stress and your levels
of anger your levels of reactivity and
also to elevate your feelings of agency
and control over your life starting with
agency and control over your physiology
your internal state is going to be vital
and what I love about the physiological
sigh is that of course it's completely
zero cost but also there's a dedicated
circuit in your brain and body for this
particular pattern of breathing we do it
spontaneously but you can do it
intentionally and it works just as well
if not better to regulate your levels of
stress that is to bring them down which
has outsize positive effects on your
mood and mental health not just in the
moment but also should improve your
confidence that when stress comes
because the world is filled with
stressors it's not if it's when when
stress comes that you will have a
physiologically scientifically supported
tool to deal with and reduce that stress
now in addition I do believe it's
important for sake of mood and mental
health to also have a tool or a protocol
to raise your stress threshold that is
to increase your capacity to deal with
life stressors without them feeling so
stressful and there are a number of
different ways to do this but they all
center around elevating your levels of
adrenaline epinephrine and
norepinephrine nor adrenaline those are
the same thing just they have multiple
names forgive me I didn't give the same
two things four names so don't blame me
blame the other scientists that did it
the point is there are several ways that
you can self-induce elevations of
noradrenaline and adrenaline and then to
learn to Anchor your mind and your
thinking to stay calm in the elevated
adrenaline States as a practice for when
stressors hit you in the outside world
and your adrenaline and noradrenaline
Spike now one of the best ways to do
this because it works the first time and
every time and is also zero cost in fact
it will save you money is to put
yourself in a cold shower or other
deliberate cold exposure environment but
most everyone has access to a cold
shower not everyone but most people and
of course by turning off the heat you're
going to reduce Heating cost right your
water bill so getting into a cold shower
for a minute or so to elevate your
levels of adrenaline and learning to
either use your breathing you could do
physiological size or to distract
yourself or whatever tools and
approaches you need to be able to stay
calm while you have elevated levels of
adrenaline in your body and the reason
deliberate cold exposure works so well
to do this is that it is pretty
non-negotiable even if you really love
cold showers or cold plunges or things
that sort you're still going to get that
elevated adrenaline and noradrenaline
it's pretty much non-negotiable you know
for the first 10 or 15 seconds that you
get into a cold plunge or a cold shower
you should fully expect yourself to feel
stress and for your breathing to
accelerate and then your goal is to try
and anchor or control your breathing in
that stressful environment the reason
for doing this is that it's a practice
it's a practice that's going to
translate to a better ability to manage
your internal State and therefore your
thinking your cognition and your ability
to make good decisions under stress it's
not about becoming Untouched by stress
it's about being able to better navigate
stress indeed I think of this as
analogous to driving in fog something
that I had to learn to do because I grew
up in the Bay Area and it can be very
foggy there sometimes and of course you
don't learn to drive in fog the first
day you learn how to drive but the first
time you hit heavy fog driving where you
can only see one reflector in front of
you at a time it is truly stressful
right you don't know if you're going to
come up on another vehicle
in an instant which of course can happen
so you have to adjust a number of things
you have to learn how to do that and
while I would never elect to drive in
fog learning to drive in fog teaches you
how to be comfortable driving in
different weather environments same
thing with driving in a rain Stormer for
you East Coasters from the Northeast
learning how to drive in a snowstorm you
would never elect to do that but once
you do it a few times you feel more
comfortable in those extreme conditions
so that's really what raising your
stress threshold is all about of course
do it safely do it under conditions in
which you're not going to get hurt or
anyone else will get hurt but learning
how to do this can be extremely
beneficial and of course deliberate cold
exposure isn't the only way but frankly
it's the most reliable way and it's the
most versatile way to do that because
you can do it in your shower or in a
cold Plunge at home so you can practice
these things again Safety First always
make sure you're not exposing yourself
to cold to the extent that you're going
to damage yourself mentally or
physically but it's a great practice and
you could probably think of other ways
to spike your adrenaline that was safe
and of course life will spike your
adrenaline so you can also use real life
as your uh you know your stress
inoculation tool and we all have to do
that anyway what I'm suggesting is that
you adopt a real-time tool physiological
size and that you adopt at least one
offline tool that you do anywhere from
one to three maybe seven days a week but
at least one day a week that you put
yourself into a cold shower deliberate
cold exposure not for sake of increasing
metabolism or anything else but really
just to learn how to calm yourself and
maintain clear cognition when stress
hits because indeed stress is going to
hit so that's the big six for improving
mood and mental health and the big six
apply that is they are the Cornerstone
for mood and mental health regardless of
who you are regardless of your age
regardless of whether or not you're
dealing with an acute or a severe mood
or mental health disorder or you find
yourself to be reasonably healthy with
respect to mood and mental health and
you simply want your mood and mental
health to be stable and or improve over
time time now the reason why the big six
those six pillars are so important for
mood and mental health and indeed form a
critical component of what Dr Paul kti
referred to as the first principles of
self-care is that those six pillars
establish a millu that is an environment
of neurochemicals including
neuromodulators such as dopamine
serotonin epinephrine norepinephrine
acetylcholine and other neurochemicals
as well as well as hormones to
testosterone estrogen prolactin cortisol
and immune molecules and on and on that
lead to a high degree of predictability
in your brain and nervous system now
what do I mean by that why would
predictability be such a key component
of mood and mental health is it really
just about knowing that you're going to
feel energized in the early part of the
day and tired at the end of the day now
that might be part of it but that's not
the major takeaway the major takeaway is
that as Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett so aptly
point pointed out your brain and indeed
your entire nervous system has a couple
of major jobs you know it has the job of
regulating your breathing and your heart
rate Etc it also has the job of
regulating your thinking and your
planning and your memory those are the
jobs of the brain and nervous system
that we normally hear about but if we
think about the more macro jobs that the
brain has the key function of the brain
certainly the parts of the brain that
are more recently evolved the ones
involved in thinking and planning Etc
are really involved involved in
generating predictions predictions about
what's going to happen next and whether
or not you're going to be prepared for
what's going to happen next and indeed
Dr Lisa Felman Barrett also beautifully
Illustrated this model of the brain as
regulating a brain body budget and moods
and a related topic which she called
affect okay I'll explain what affect is
in a moment setting the stage for being
able to better predict what's going to
happen next and therefore
regulating your mood in the moment let's
just take a moment and explore that
statement in a little bit more detail
essentially what she was saying and what
I'm now again saying is that your brain
and body go through different states
your state at a given moment can be
labeled as your affect your affect
includes a lot of different things
including levels of autonomic arousal
levels of hormones levels of
transmitters all of that stuff but it
falls under the umbrella of affect
affect essentially sets the stage for
particular emotions to be more likely or
less likely to emerge so emotion and
affect aren't the same thing affect is a
bit more General and sort of undergirds
the possibility of having certain moods
like feeling elated happy or sad or
depressed it really sets the general
stage for different types of specific
emotions even highly specific emotions
so in that way when you're taking care
of the big six when you're tending to
these six pillars on a regular basis and
I should point out that we really want
to tend to those six pillars every
single day or every single 24 hours we
really need to make those a regular
investment to the extent that we can
when we do that we create a
neurochemical and a neural milu that
allows the brain to be in a better
predictive state it allows the brain to
give rise to a certain aex spelled
a CS so affex
that lead to certain emotions being more
or less likely to occur put very simply
when we're tending to those six pillars
on a regular basis we feel better more
generally and therefore the emotions
that we tend to have under different
conditions even conditions of a
difficult interaction with a cooworker
or with a family member tend to be more
positive than if we are not tending to
those six pillars now in some sense
that's sort of a duh statement for
instance if you're sleep deprived if
you're not fed well like you haven't
eaten in a few hours of course you're
going to be more irritable you're going
to be more reactive you are going to be
more emotionally labile but sleep and
nutrition are just two of those six core
pillars when we talk about those core
pillars and the necessity for tending to
them on a regular every 24-hour basis
what we're really talking about is
creating a millu within our brain and
nervous system that allows the nervous
system to do what it does best and in
fact what its main job is to do which is
to predict what's going to happen next
because as Lisa Feldman Barrett pointed
out emotions are really context
dependent states that allow us to
navigate not just our present
circumstances but they are our nervous
system and brain's best guess about the
circumstances that we are soon going to
encounter now I don't offer you all of
that as kind of a a bunch of you know
Tangled mess of nerd speak to confuse
you what I'm saying is that by tending
to those six core pillars you are
shifting the likely aects that you will
EXP exp erience and therefore the likely
emotions that you'll experience so
you're biasing your whole system towards
more positive affect and more positive
emotions regardless of what your life
circumstances happen to be and the
stressors that you encounter and indeed
you also are including that six pillar
of stress control so when those
stressors arrive you will be better able
to navigate them now this view of
emotion regulation of mood and mental
health is certainly not a novel concept
people have talked about the
physiological regulation of mood from
the time of William James and even
earlier you know it's been a
long-standing question for instance or
debate in Psychology and philosophy you
know do we feel anxiety in our body and
then label it as anxiety or do we feel
anxiety in our mind and then our body
follows that's been a long-standing
debate and frankly there's evidence on
both sides which leads me to the
conclusion I think most neurobiologists
and psychologists to the conclusion that
those things are interrelated in a way
that we can't really dissociate them
completely at any level right when your
heart rate goes up and you start
breathing thing faster you know if I
were to induce that state in you you'd
probably interpret that as feeling
anxious in addition to that something
can make you anxious before your heart
rate and breathing increases and then
your heart rate and breathing increases
so no need to tease those apart but if
you think about the brain in large part
as a prediction machine and your brain
as a metabolic regulator it's trying to
decide which organs need resources how
much resource can I dedicate to thinking
to creativity to enjoying social
interaction to paying attention to what
somebody else is is saying as opposed to
what's going on inside my body all of
those major functions of the brain as
they relate to affect and emotions are
going to be best supported that is
biased toward positive mood positive
affect positive emotions and therefore
positive mental health outcomes when
we're tending to those six pillars Dr
Lisa feldin Barrett referred to that
whole process as the brain regulating a
brain body budget and she had beautiful
analogies for that budget and that's
what led to the description of social
interactions is either generating
savings or being neutral or generating a
taxed feeling literally taxing that
brain body budget and I love that
concept and it's one that you can keep
in mind and indeed we can inject a lot
of specificity into this whole process
of improving mood and mental health
through specific protocols if you simply
remember if you make a daily investment
in the six core pillars you are building
up that brain body budget you will have
more energetic resources to spend on
whatever life circumstances come your
way now before we move into a discussion
about protocols for how to better
understand your life narrative to
enhance your sense of self and
confidence and things of that theme I
briefly want to mention that of course
there are known tools out there in the
medical community and psychological
Community for improving mood and mental
health and while there are a variety of
tools one of the main tools of the
psychiatrist is prescription drugs that
Target specific neuromodulator systems
in the brain and body for instance SSR
selective serotonin reuptake Inhibitors
or atypical anti-depressants that Target
the dopamine and epinephrine system such
as well Butrin bryone or other types of
anti-depressants or for instance
nowadays there's a lot of growing
excitement about clinical trials using
relatively High dosages of psilocybin
which by the way way closely mimics the
chemical serotonin that's right
psilocybin which is converted to salicin
in the brain if you look at it
chemically it looks very much like
serotonin although it has distinct
effects from serotonin I talked about
psilocybin and what's being done in
terms of the clinical trials safety
considerations I talked about the
potential Hazard considerations and
where the legality and all of that is
going in that episode if you want to
check that out but the reason I'm taking
a moment to mention these drugs things
like ssris prox lat talopram
Wellbutrin cybin and so on is that all
of them Target specific neuromodulator
systems in the brain and body and at the
same time it's fairly clear that mood
disorders such as major depression are
not necessarily deficits in things like
serotonin or dopamine they can be but
most often they are not so why are such
drugs prescribed for mood disorders and
for mental health disorders well because
if specific neuromodulators like
serotonin dopamine or epinephrine are
dramatically increased above
Baseline that affords the brain the
ability to rewire itself really the way
to think about ssris or atypical
anti-depressants or psilocybin for the
treatment of major
depression is really to think about them
as chemical tools to open or access
neuroplasticity and that's why it's oh
so important that those drugs be
combined with talk therapy where people
are actively working through the sources
the real life sources and the historical
sources maybe even the trauma based
sources of their depression and I
mention this because you know there's a
lot of debate nowadays as to whether or
not you know these drugs are useful
whether or not the side effect profiles
justify their use whether or not you
know they are applicable to Young
populations you know there's a lot of
debate about this and certainly in the
case of the psychedelics there's a lot a
lot of debate because this is newly
emerging area and there's still not a
lot of data although it's starting to
you know increase over time but the key
Point here is that all of these drugs
have the potential to work in some
people not others some people you know
they simply don't work for and they
cause more problems than solutions they
solve but they tend to work by
increasing the propensity for
neuroplasticity by changing the
neuromodulator milu in the brain and
this is an important point when thinking
about tool tools for enhancing mood and
mental health that when we think about
tools for enhancing mood and mental
health and next of course we are going
to talk about the tools that are
specifically designed to Target a
specific aspect of one's life story or
concept of self all of that is always
operating on a backdrop of two things
that overall neurochemical millu and
autonomic function that the six pillars
relate to and support if we're tending
to those but any Improvement in mood and
mental health that's it's going to be
significant it's going to be noticeable
and it's going to be stable it's going
to be pervasive over time is going to
require that some degree of neural
plasticity some degree of neural
rewiring occur so I'm not bringing up
the topic of these particular drug tools
to say that they are the best way to
improve mood and mental health I'm
certainly not saying that they are but
one way to potentially improve mood and
mental health and if they are going to
work they always work best when done in
concert with talk therapy because they
are opening the opportunity for
neuroplastic icity but then that
neuroplasticity has to be directed
toward a particular endpoint there has
to be specific work that's being done by
the individual or ideally the individual
with an expert trained clinically
certified therapist or psychologist or
psychiatrist in order to make sure that
the neuroplastic changes that occur lead
to long-standing improvements in mood
and mental health over time indeed the
drugs that I just described were
originally designed as tools to to allow
people to access changes within their
brain that would then allow them to
enhance mood and mental health but not
have to rely on the drugs themselves for
improved mood and mental health and
along those lines I'm sure some of you
out there are thinking about the
supplement based or nutrition-based
approaches to enhancing these
neuromodulators and indeed while they
don't have the same potency as things
like well Butrin and ssris at increasing
things like dopamine and serotonin
respectively there is a growing number
of people out there that are relying on
say daily supplementation with anywhere
from 1 to three grams with of el
tyrosine you know amino acid precursor
to dopamine combined with often you know
300 to 600 milligrams of alpha GPC as a
way to enhance dopamine and
acetylcholine and to set the stage for
elevated levels of neuroplasticity but
it's very important to point out that
the amino acid precursors to the various
neuromodulators like El tyrosine like El
tryptophan so El tyrosine precursor to
dopamine ELP toan precursor to serotonin
and so on that those don't have the same
degree of potency that is ability to
enhance those neuromodulators and so the
extent to which they enrich the
possibility for neuroplasticity Still
Remains somewhat obscure there haven't
been clinical trials on that yet at
least not clinical trials that I am
aware of so I mention all of that stuff
about drugs whether or not it's
psychedelics or whether or not it's
prescription anti-depressants or whether
or not people are using a supplement
based amino acid based protocol for
increasing certain neurom modulators I
feel was important to mention all of
that because well first of all it's
quite prominent out there certainly in
the case of prescription
anti-depressants and there's growing
prominence and use of relatively high do
psilocybin again always in done with
support talk therapy this is done in the
legal setting I said legal not illegal a
legal setting with a board certified
therapist this is being done on
University campuses within research lab
and of course I acknowledge that there
are people who are using these compounds
outside the realm of the University
clinical study environment so I mention
these chemicals not because I'm pointing
to them as the path to improved mood and
mental health they can be but they
aren't always and as I mentioned before
they can sometimes cause problems that
lead people to wish that they hadn't
taken them or to decide to not take them
any further a decision that absolutely
has to be made with a healthc care
professional who's well certified to do
that but I'm mentioning these tools
because I want to understand if they
work why they work and one key point
that was really emphasized by Dr Paul
kti who as I mentioned before is a
psychiatrist so he uses pharmacology in
his practice although he uses other
non-pharmacologic tools as well is that
these pharmacologic tools are never to
be viewed as the Beall endall of
enhancing mood and mental health they
are but one path to improving mood and
mental health and indeed should be
viewed as a path to getting people who
are otherwise unable to engage in those
six core pillars those first principles
of mental health to be able to do those
things on a regular basis and then
perhaps based on a discussion with their
clinician these people could come off
those pharmacologic agents maybe yes
maybe no it depends on the individual it
depends on the circumstances but those
core six pillars those first principles
of mental health that include but are
not limited to those core six pillars
are absolutely essential there's no drug
that can replace those Cor six pillars
I'd like to take a quick break and thank
our sponsor insid tracker insid tracker
is a personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and
DNA to help you better understand your
body and help you reach your health
goals I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done for the
simple reason that many of the factors
that impact your immediate and long-term
Health can only be analyzed from a
quality blood test a major problem with
a lot of blood tests out there however
is that you get information back about
metabolic factors lipids and hormones
and so so forth but you don't know what
to do with that information with insid
tracker they make it very easy because
they have a personalized platform that
allows you to see the levels of all
those things metabolic factors lipids
hormones Etc but it gives you specific
directives that you can follow that
relate to nutrition behavioral
modifications supplements Etc that can
help you bring those numbers into the
ranges that are optimal for you if you'd
like to try inside tracker you can go to
insidetracker
docomo to get 20% off any of insid
tracker's plans again that's inside s
tracker.com huberman okay so setting
aside the core six pillars let's now
talk about other tools for mood and
mental health that center around really
what we more typically think of when we
think of mood and mental health which is
emotions when Dr Lisa Felman Barrett was
a guest on the podcast she said
something that was really incredible and
it's something that's strongly grounded
in excellent scientific data which is
the more specificity that we can put to
labeling our emotions the better off
we're going to be in terms of our
overall mental health let me restate
that the more specific language that we
can put to our own internal emotions
even if that language is just to
ourselves in our own internal narrative
we don't even have to speak out what
those labels are the better that we're
going to feel over time and indeed this
effect can be quite rapid and indeed Dr
Lisa Felman Barrett has done research on
this very specific topic topic it's
something that's referred to as
emotional granularity so while some of
us move through life with a sort of what
I call emogif of emotions you know you
got your happy face happy your sad face
sad you you're angry depressed anxious
you know those are labels for emotional
states or you could think of them as AFF
effects or emotions I think of them as
emotions but they're not very specific
they're pretty broad bins we say sad or
depressed or super depressed or super
sad anxious panic and we think of that
as Nuance but it's not very nuanced and
Lisa's laboratory and other Laboratories
have explored two things first if people
are asked to or encouraged to put more
granularity more specificity on what
they're feeling then it seems that their
levels of emotional processing are
better overall how does that translate
to emotions well it translates to better
overall feelings of well-being when one
is placing more specificity on positive
emotions and the flip side is also true
so this is important to know if one
places more specificity on negative
emotions it also can enhance one's kind
of experience of those negative emotions
now that means that this is a two-sided
blade all right this isn't always a good
thing and if one is thinking about
protocols for improving mood and mental
health the data make very clear that
adding more specificity to our positive
emotion in terms of the language we use
but also just the depth with which we
process and think about those positive
experiences can be very beneficial for
us so there are two studies that I'd
like to highlight that relate to this
the first is entitled effective
self-monitoring through experience
sampling On Emotion differentiation in
depression and the second study is
entitled emotional granularity increases
with intensive ambulatory assessment
methodological and individual factors
influence how much now each of these
studies focus on something slightly
different the first study was mainly
focused on people who have depression
and they were cued several if not many
times per day to just think about and
report on their emotional state and that
was done in order to get people to place
more granularity more specificity on
what they're feeling but also simply to
tap into how they're feeling on a more
regular basis throughout the day the
second study which is one that included
Dr Lisa Felman bear as an author was
slightly different because it focused on
non- depressed individuals and it cued
them to touch into their emotions more
times per day and it also included some
physiological measurements and one in
particular that we're going to talk
about in some detail now I don't have
time to go into all the details of these
studies I may do that in a future
podcast episode but the key takeaways
are very important for all of us to know
which are first of
all the more often that you can ask
yourself you know what am I really
feeling right now how do I feel and and
this is so critical
the more that you force yourself to not
use broad labels or simply veilance
labels veilance labels are good or okay
or bad and instead understand that good
is not an emotion okay is not an emotion
bad is not an emotion but rather saying
you know I feel you know curious but a
little anxious if that happens to be the
case or I feel you know bored um but you
know also a little bit in positive
anticipation about what's going to
happen tomorrow things of that sort
putting more nuance and specificity on
your emotions but also touching into or
thinking about your own emotional states
more times per day clearly has positive
outcomes for mood and mental health and
the reasons for that are incredibly
interesting and this is something
everybody should understand why would it
be that putting more specificity on what
we're feeling so perhaps just in our own
heads like thinking okay how do I feel
right now like if I were to do that
right now I'd say I feel
energized and happy I do I really enjoy
doing what I'm doing so I wouldn't say
I'm like off the chart in awe or Elation
but I'm very happy and I feel energized
you know earlier today I was feeling a
little bit fatigued and a little bit
confused because I was trying to sort
out something and it wasn't making sense
to me um so assessments like that which
can be told to somebody else or that we
just hold internally
done repeatedly throughout the day
anywhere from three to six times
throughout the day just periodically
pinging ourselves maybe you set an alarm
or maybe you just decide to every once
in a while you know maybe every time you
you go into an elevator or every time
you go up a flight of stairs you just
ask yourself yeah how do I feel right
now and thinking about that for a moment
and you don't have to write it down
although I suppose you could it turns
out that just that practice can really
enhance our so-called emotional
granularity that can enhance our
positive emotions and affect and in
addition it provides us a better
sensitivity to better understand those
negative emotions which sounds like it
might be a bad thing but those negative
emotions have information in them right
this is one thing that's often lost in
those broad categorizations of anxious
or sad or depressed and keep in mind of
course that some people are genuinely
clinically depressed and that needs to
be taken extremely seriously just like
some people are genuinely clinically
anxious and that needs to be taken
seriously but most of us when we throw
out the words depressed angry sad we're
not using enough nuance and it doesn't
really apply to our internal States or
the circumstances that we're in and as a
consequence we suffer it's not just
about communicating our emotions we
suffer because the data say that the
more Nuance the more emotional
granularity that we have the richer is
our experience of the positive aspects
of life and the more effectively we can
navigate the negative aspects of life
right again negative emotions perhaps
isn't the best way to even describe
negative emotions because that label
negative implies that we should avoid it
and in fact those negative emotions
provide a lot of information about
perhaps social interactions that we
should seek to avoid in the future and
so on and so forth now one of the most
interesting things about this whole
process of increasing emotional
granularity and touching in several
times per day into how we feel something
that's completely zero cost takes just a
moment to do that we can get much better
at over over time that was clearly seen
in these studies that people get much
better at doing this it becomes more
fasile for them very quickly is that it
correlates with improvements in
physiological metrics that relate to
overall improvements in mood and mental
health and the specific physiological
metric that I'm referring to is
so-called vagal tone some of you have
perhaps heard of the vagus nerve it's
the tenth cranial nerve it's an
extensive peripheral nerve that it goes
out of the brain kind at the level of
the the neck uh it's one of the cranial
nerves that extends um to essentially
all the organs of the body the heart the
lungs Etc but it's a two-way street it's
a super highway of nerves out of the
brain and into the body and it's a super
highway of nerves back from the bodily
organs to the brain and it's involved in
regulating a lot of so-call autonomic
function so how fast our heart rate is
how fast our breathing is rates of
digestion and all of that weaves
together to create those things that we
call aect our internal States so without
going into a ton of detail about the
Vagas nerve there's something that's
called cardiac vagal control cardiac
vagal control is the extent to which
that vagus nerve can impact your heart
rate and your overall feelings of calm
or alertness now the simple way to think
about this is more commonly referred to
as heart rate variability heart rate
variability is simply the distance
between your heartbeats or rather the
time between your Heartbeats which we
know if those timings between your
heartbeats are somewhat variable that is
correlated with positive physical and
mental health outcomes one of the ways
that you can increase heart rate
variability is to get regular
cardiovascular exercise as well as doing
resistance exercise and no surprise
getting sufficient amounts of quality
sleep each night is also going to be
very beneficial for heart rate
variability now exercise and sleep of
course are wonderful but it turns out
that there's also
a very rapid way to increase heart rate
variability by activating the vagal
innervation of the heart and the way
that the heart and some other circuits
within the so-called brain stem interact
and that's through something called
respiratory sinus arhythmia respiratory
sinus arhythmia can be summarized very
simply by saying when you inhale you
speed your heart rate up and when you
exhale you slow your heart rate down and
it's that exhale slowing your heart rate
down that's mediated by the vagus nerve
now there's a more thorough description
of that which I'll just give you now and
it's not that lengthy so here's how it
goes when you inhale your diaphragm
actually moves down and as a consequence
your heart actually gets a little bigger
it has a little more space as a
consequence the fluid in your heart
moves a little more slowly per unit
volume and there's a neural signal to
speed the heart up conversely when you
exhale the diaphragm moves up that means
there's a little less space for the
heart in the general area where it's
sitting so the heart gets a little bit
smaller a little more compact that means
that the fluid in your heart is moving
more quickly through that smaller space
and there's a neural signal mediated by
the Vagas to slow the heart down so
that's why inhal speed your heart up and
exhales slow your heart down that is the
basis of so-called RSA or respiratory
sinus arhythmia now what does any of
that have to do
with the granularity of language that we
place on our emotions turns out there's
several studies showing that when
people place more descriptive
granularity on their emotions that is
correlated with okay it's not causal but
it's correlated with improvements in
respiratory sinus arhythmia which we
know correlate with improvements in
heart rate variability indeed it's one
of the major bases for heart rate
variability which we know is correlated
with not just positive physical health
outcomes but positive mental health
outcomes including lower levels of
anxiety improved sleep and overall
levels of mood this is a topic that I'm
very familiar with because last year my
laboratory at Stanford University School
of Medicine in collaboration with a
colleague of mine Dr David Spiegel our
associate chair of Psychiatry also at
Stanford University School of Medicine
published a clinical trial and cell
reports medicine showing that there's a
particular pattern of breathing that
people can do for just 5 minutes per day
that is effective in significantly
improving various metrics related to
mood and reducing anxiety and also
improving sleep although I should say
the protocol I'm about to describe
didn't uniformly improve all of those
metrics it had a bigger effect on some
versus others I'll provide a link to
that study in the show note captions but
if you're wondering what this protocol
is that people did for 5 minutes a day
that allowed them to by the way
pervasively improve their mood so it
wasn't just their mood while they were
doing this five minute a day protocol it
was improvements in mood Around the
Clock essentially as well as
improvements in other physiological
metrics and other aspects of those six
core pillars it was that physiological
sigh that we talked about earlier
although in this case we didn't have
people do just one physiological sigh we
had people set aside five minutes per
day so set a timer for 5 minutes they
could sit or lie down they could do it
anytime of day and we just had them
repeat that physiological sigh for a
duration of 5 minutes total so that they
would do two inhales through the nose
and then a full exhale to lungs empty
through the mouth then they would do it
again and then they would do it again
and again until those five minutes were
completed again the outcome of that
clinical trial was that that particular
pattern of breathing which we called
cyclic physiological sighing for five
minutes per day again done any time of
day had the most positive outcomes in
terms of improving mood and mental
health and autonomic function those
things related to sleep and heart rate
variability so that's a very simple very
minimal time investment zero cost tool
that anyone can use that again improves
various metrics of physical health but
also improves metrics of mental health
and it ties right back in with what was
observed in the work by Dr Lisa Feldman
Barrett exploring how putting more word
label emotional granularity on one's
emotional states positively impact our
physiological State and the fact that
thinking about our emotions more
frequently throughout the day and
deliberately putting more label
granularity on those emotions frequently
throughout the day is correlated with
this Improvement in respiratory sinus
arhythmia and heart rate variability the
fact that these things all relate to one
another should not surprise us because
indeed there's a previous paper this is
a quite extensive review actually it's a
very nice review it's one that I
encourage anyone who's interested in
these topics to explore especially
psychologists who might have a interest
in physiology or psychiatrists or simply
people who are interested in mindbody
stuff this is a review published in 2017
in the journal biological psychology
entitled cardiac vagal control as a
marker of emotion regulation in healthy
adults a review and again it's a really
wonderful literature review of the
peer-reviewed primary research which
really establishes that this thing vagal
tone our ability to kind of put the
brakes on our autonomic nervous system
and slow our heart rate down
deliberately through our breathing and
perhaps even just by stopping and
reflecting on what our emotional states
are is really beneficial for our overall
mood and mental health and I want to
highlight bold and underline that word
overall because it's not just the case
that people experience elevated mood and
mental health in the moments where they
stop and go oh how am I feeling oh you
know am I feeling you know bored or
agitated do I feel particularly excited
sure that can have some impact on
physiological metrics and mood and
mental health but in all of these
studies the outcome seems to be that
people's overall levels of mood and
mental health are enhanced not just
while they're thinking about their
emotions or doing this five minute a day
cyclic sighing but Around the Clock
which is really terrific because I think
that's what most all of us want which is
improve mood and mental health not just
in the moments when we do a practice or
in the few minutes afterwards but 24
hours a day I suppose we might segment
out sleep during which you know
hopefully we're having great dreams as
opposed to other kinds of dreams but the
point is everyone I have to imagine
would like to feel better and have
elevated mood and mental health during
the times when they're awake and indeed
these sorts of protocols have been shown
to do that or so say the scientific data
now we are going to discuss the tools
for enhancing mood and mental health
gleaned from the four episode guest
series with Dr Paul Ki who is a medical
doctor specializing in Psychiatry he
also has particular expertise in trauma
however the four episode guest series
that we did with Dr kti was really about
exploring the self as well as tools and
protocols for not just gaining a better
understanding of oneself but also for
gaining a better understanding and tools
for relating to others AKA relationships
thread through the series was a model of
the mind and how it works to create
everything from feelings thoughts to
behaviors that Dr Paul Conti described
as an iceberg model and I perhaps should
refer you to the fact that he actually
Drew out this model and we provided it
as a zeroc cost PDF in the show note
captions for every single one of those
episodes in that four episode series we
also provide a link to this model in the
show note captions for this tools
episode the model is called the iceberg
model and as the name suggests it
resembles an iceberg in which the vast
majority of our mind's processing occurs
below our conscious awareness in our
unconscious mind so that's the portion
of the iceberg that resides below the
surface whereas the portion of our
mental processing that we are aware of
resides above the water surface the
so-called conscious mind so a key aspect
of the iceberg model is that the
unconscious mind is responsible for the
vast majority of our feelings thoughts
and behaviors but that we are not aware
of how this unconscious mind is doing
that and by extension the tool and
protocols that Dr Ki described largely
deal with going into the unconscious and
figuring out how the unconscious
processing is influencing our conscious
processing both in healthy and in
unhealthy ways and when we say in
healthy and unhealthy ways we're largely
referring to the presence of defenses so
some of you have perhaps heard of
defenses before some defenses can indeed
be healthy and others are unhealthy
there are defenses such as projection
sublimation denial and during the course
of that four episode series Dr kti
explains how projections are not always
bad for us indeed they can protect us
from Panic from severe trauma but they
also can create difficulties in
processing our own understanding of self
and of our life experiences in ways that
can actually be damaging to us so a key
takeaway from that four episode series
is to understand and acknowledge that
your unconscious mind is driving much of
what you feel think and do however by
doing structured exploration of the self
and we'll talk about how to do that one
can gain better understanding of how
that unconscious processing is
influencing what you think feel believe
and do so once you accept the important
role of the unconscious mind and you
make the decision that you want to
better understand how your unconscious
mind and conscious mind are in this
constant dialogue and how you can have
that dialogue better serve you there are
a series of actionable tools that you
can do that will allow you to better
understand yourself and how you relate
to others
and the first of these tools is to
really understand your self-concept now
of course most all of us know our own
name rarely do we ever forget that name
we have some concept of where we're from
who our parents are what our present and
future goals might be where we've
succeeded where we failed in life and on
and on but the self-concept goes far
beyond that sort of CV list or our
biography of self indeed the
self-concept has a lot to do with our
self-confidence our feeling ings of
ability both to overcome challenges but
also our ability to serve the world that
we're in and our ability to change
ourselves over time now of course the
degree to which somebody might have
confidence or less confidence or the
degree to which somebody feels that they
can exert influence on their environment
and their goals is of course going to
vary based on their personal history but
as Dr kti explained even independent of
all that if one puts in some work to
better understand their self-concept to
to really get a clear picture of
oneself from that one can develop more
agency with which to pursue one's
aspirations and to reach their goals and
the key concept here is one that's
particularly powerful for both exploring
and building up one's concept of self
and that's to consciously and
deliberately build a life narrative now
a simple way to do this that can be very
effective is to create a series of
folders or documents it could even be a
stack of papers I prefer to do this in
electronic form and I confess that even
before learning about this tool from Dr
Ki I had initiated doing this tool
starting back in
2015 and it's fairly straightforward but
as I mentioned before it can be very
powerful and it simply consists of
building out separate folders or pieces
of paper and this could be done
electronically or on real world paper
with paper and pen or paper and pencil
and essentially what you do is you're
going to divide your life history into
some regular increments so for for me
the way that I did this is I created a
folder on my laptop that I actually
called lifetime so that's the title of
the main folder and then within that
folder I have a series of folders Each
of which spans a particular phase of my
life so 0 to 5 years of age 6 to 10
years of age 11 to 15 years of age and
so on and so forth now I'm 48 years old
so I have folders that extend to age 50
currently although I will add folders
going forward very soon and the idea
here is that for each of those folders
you're going to place a single word
document into that folder and then on
that word document you're not going to
journal you're not going to do any sort
of extensive writing rather You're
simply going to put down bullet points
with titles it could be one or two
sentences but typically it's just a few
words describing some of the key
Milestone events that you remember from
that particular phase of your life so
just for sake of example I'll read off
some of the things that are included in
the folders for my particular lifetime
narrative but of course this relates to
my lifetime narrative you should of
course put the milestones and key bullet
points that relate to your lifetime
narrative but again just to give you a
sense of the sorts of things that made
it into this folder in my six years old
to 11 year-old folder um on that
document I put where I was living at
that time the city I was living the
school that I went to I put a couple of
teachers names uh teachers that had a
particular influence on me um a
particular summer camp experience um
that was not a traumatic experience by
the way it was a happy experience but
for me it turned out to be a very
transformative one and then there are a
couple other things in there that are
just Recollections of childhood's
friends names okay so seemingly mundane
information perhaps but it looks more or
less like a biography and yet other
folders so for instance uh the folder
that spans from 25 to 30 years of age is
the time that I was in graduate school
so it includes a note about graduate
school a note about particular hobbies
that I was interested in in addition to
my scientific search at the time a
couple of key relationships a couple of
key relationship challenges as well as
some things that at that time I was
processing about prior years in
particular my teen years in high school
now the key thing here is that whatever
goes into these folders is what's
important to you it could be positive
events it could be negative events it
could be events that for whatever reason
you remember and keep surfacing in your
mind that you think might be interesting
or important at some later time or that
you're concerned you might forget in
fact that might be a really good me for
whether or not you include something in
these folders or not if there's
something that you want to make sure
that you never forget but that you think
you might forget I would encourage you
to put it onto that word document and
put it into that particular folder again
this isn't about creating a coherent
life story this is about creating a
series of segments of small collections
of key life events positive negative
neutral inspiring basically anything
that was Salient for you at that
particular time and of course if you
want to put Reflections about those
particular events into that word
document you're more than welcome to do
that but the basis of this self-concept
developing exercise is just that it's to
develop a historical sense of yourself
of course bringing you up to present day
where you will continue to add things to
whatever Word document goes into that
particular folder for the age you happen
to be now now for some of you this kind
of autobiographical bullet pointing
might seem like it's just that some
attempt to build or write an
autobiography but it's very important to
remember that these folders are for you
these folders are not about writing a
book about your life history although if
you decide to do that with these folders
at some point down the line you know
that sounds great but that's not the
goal here the goal is for you to build a
structured narrative representation of
events that were key in your life and as
described in the series with Dr kti this
goes Way Beyond just understanding your
past this is really about understanding
past it's about understanding yourself
at present and indeed it threads into
your goals and aspirations for the
future an important thing to understand
about this tool or protocol is that it
also has a incredible ability to Anchor
you in your perception of the passage of
time you know some of us track the
passage of time better than others both
within the day and across days and years
and so forth but this exercise in
particular is very good at allowing you
to see you know how much time you
devoted at a given stage of your life to
a given Endeavor whether or not you're
stuck in patterns whereby you're still
engaging in certain types of things
professionally or relationship wise or
in any other number of different ways
that have you in a pattern that may or
may not be serving you well I want to
emphasize again that this exercise is
not about goal setting it's about your
ability to build a structured narrative
pattern from which you can look at it
and then make a determination as to
whether or not you know you feel that
you're currently on the right path for
you but it's not about projecting
forward as to what your goals are we'll
soon talk about that we'll talk about
goals and aspirations in a moment this
is really about better understanding
what led you up to the place that you
are now and it really helps you pinpoint
the keyw work that you need to do in
terms of exploring your unconscious and
conscious mind using some tools that
we're going to get into subsequently so
there's really no strict rules about how
to do this exactly except that I do
encourage you to make those increments
across your lifespan manageable I
wouldn't suggest doing it one for every
year I wouldn't suggest a folder one for
every 10 years I think a 3 to 5 year
increments seem like a more reasonable
and tractable way to go about this so
that's one of the sorts of tools that Dr
Ki referred to as to how to build up
one's self-concept which directly
relates to things such as our confidence
our ability to track our own behavior
understand some of our motivations both
conscious and unconscious but of course
that practice is mainly a conscious
exercise it's it's really not tapping
directly into the unconscious in any
kind of direct way as far as we know now
we can contrast that with the tools and
protocols that are designed to tap into
the unconscious mind and of course there
are a number of different ways to do
this that were discussed in that four
episode series with Dr Ki but one of the
most powerful ways to do this is by
thinking about and indeed sometimes
writing about or even analyzing one's
dreams now dream analysis is something
for which you can find a lot of books
out there there are a lot of theories
there's also a lot of AR arent that
perhaps dream analysis which has roots
in fraudi and psychology as well as
other Traditions is perhaps not accurate
I don't think we want to consider
whether or not dream analysis is
accurate rather I think we should just
acknowledge that when we are dreaming in
particular the dreams that we have
toward the later part of our night which
are the dreams associated with rapid eye
movement sleep that tend to be very
emotionally Laden dreams as compared to
the dreams that we have earlier in the
night well when we consider the content
of those dreams even even if we're not
trying to interpret them it's very clear
that those dreams reflect the
unconscious mind controlling more of our
internal dialogue or what we are
experiencing at that time whereas when
we are awake our conscious mind tends to
take over more of the narrative the
internal narrative and the control of
our feelings thoughts and behaviors but
as I mentioned before the unconscious
mind is always exerting an influence
regardless of whether or not we are
sleep or awake with that said one way to
explore the unconscious mind and to
begin to get a better understand about
how it might be influencing our waking
States and behaviors is to actually
record and think about one's dreams now
of course some people remember their
dreams on a regular basis other people
don't some people actually believe that
they don't dream studies out of sleep
Laboratories at Stanford University of
Pennsylvania Harvard and elsewhere all
generally agree that everybody dreams
but not everybody remembers their dreams
so if you're interested in tapping into
an understanding of what your dreams are
telling you which is basically a way of
saying what your unconscious mind or
dialogue consists of I highly recommend
putting a journal so this would be any
kind of paper and pen or paper and
pencil type journal and the idea is this
if you wake up and you can remember your
dream write down a few key bullet points
from that dream if you feel you can
write out the dream in a very kind of
linear narrative this happened then that
happened then this happened then that
happened great but most most people find
that their memory of their dream is
rather fragmentary other people can't
remember their dream or at least they
wake up they feel like they were having
a dream but they can't remember all of
it or key components of it and for that
I suggest that you try keeping your body
completely still and closing your eyes
once again we don't quite understand why
this is but when you look at the
literature on dream recollection it
seems that by keeping one's body
completely still with eyes closed we
have better access to whatever the
contents of the dream that just occurred
were okay so if you wake up and you
can't remember your dreams try lying
still for a few minutes and keeping your
eyes closed and seeing whether or not
that helps surface the content of that
dream other people find that they get up
they get out of bed and then sometime in
the middle of the morning maybe even
later in the day the contents of a dream
will just come to them well if that
happens great I also highly recommend
that you have a way to write down the
contents of the of that dream now what
you're looking for when you do this sort
of tool or protocol I encourage you to
be wary of any immediate interpretation
of for instance okay animals in a dream
mean children although they could you
know there's not a lot of science that
really supports that as a firm statement
and of course there are books out there
and podcasts and a ton of information
trying to help you interpret your dreams
and while some of that can be fun and
not all of it is entirely useless the
goal here is not to interpret your
dreams the goal here is to start
recording some of the key takeaways
Maybe maybe even the entire Narrative of
the dreams that you have just prior to
waking as a way to try and understand
some of the themes that are occurring
and recurring in the dialogue that
exists within your unconscious mind so a
key aspect of this tool is that you're
not going to take any one dream as an
enormously informative dream it might be
but more important in this particular
tool is to write down the themes of a
particular dream and then see whether or
not those particular themes resurface
again and again across different nights
or across different dreams the idea here
is that things that are repeating
thematically will show up as different
components in different dreams but that
by keeping a dream journal you can start
to identify some of these patterns that
are occurring from one dream to the next
as opposed to having the same dream over
and over but the point here is that you
can explore the contents and the themes
that's really the most important word
here the themes of your unconscious mind
that is a occurring if you start
thinking about what's recurring during
your dreams because dreams are a time
when your unconscious mind is dominating
The Narrative within your mind and brain
now for those of you that dream a lot
and remember your dreams as well as for
those of you that do not I would also
encourage you to explore the contents of
your thinking that is thinking about
your thinking during so-called Lial
States and the Lial State during which
this can be particularly useful is Right
upon waking so this is different than
thinking about what you were dreaming
about this is about keeping your eyes
closed and body still we do think that
that's important for doing this well
because once you start moving your body
you open your eyes and you start
bringing in sensory experience for that
day your mind dramatically shifts
towards conscious processing but in that
Lial State between sleeping and awake
when you wake up and you're a little
sleepy maybe you don't want to get out
of bed this happens to me all too often
try closing your eyes and remaining
perfectly still for maybe one to three
minutes maybe five minutes and just pay
attention to where your mind goes now
you might fall back asleep be mindful of
that depending on what you need to do
that morning but a lot of people will
find that their mind goes into this
place that's neither sleep nor awake
right this is a state that very much
resembles the state people achieve in
things like Yoga Nidra yoga sleep or in
non-sleep deep rest although it tends to
be more dominated by the unconscious
mind a little bit more sleep-like now
some people find this practice to be
difficult because they're the sort of
people that wake up and they're just
immediately ready to go most people
however myself included find that when
they wake up you know the mind isn't
completely alert yet and you can use
that period again just maybe two or
three minutes maybe five minutes to
start to pay attention to the contents
of your thinking see whether or not your
thinking migrates from you know
something related to work or to
relationship or to self or to something
you want to do or something that you're
anxious about and so on and so on and
here too you'll want to write this down
so this is very much like the dream
journaling we just talked about but it's
slightly easier for most people to
access especially people who have a hard
time remembering their dreams and again
it's an opportunity to access some of
the contents of your unconscious mind to
learn to look at and see what's going on
in your unconscious mind in a way that's
very difficult if not impossible to do
unless you're working with somebody
who's very good at accessing
unconscious such as a skilled
psychiatrist or psychoanalyst and in
that way allowing you to do
introspective work which is not
structured in terms of thinking trying
to think about like what do I want
what's going on you know why did they do
that why did I react that way nothing
like that you're simply observing your
mind and seeing what's geysering up from
the unconscious that is you're getting a
portal into that portion of the iceberg
that resides below the surface of the
water the next set of tools for
exploring the self
self-concept Etc from that four episode
series with Dr Ki is journaling I'm
going to do an entire episode of The
hubman Lab podcast about journaling and
there are a lot of different kinds of
journaling and fortunately there are a
lot of great peer-reviewed studies about
the power of journaling for processing
all sorts of things like emotional
states trauma Etc they're basically two
categories of journaling that are very
useful to carry out on a consistent
basis and when I say consistent basis
that could mean every day or it could
mean three times a week it could even be
once a week there really no hard and
fast rules about this but when we think
about journaling there really two main
styles of journaling one is going to be
free associative journaling sometimes
people talk about this as a data dump
right typically people will talk about
the data dump as the morning notes which
is when you wake up in the morning you
know you got a lot on your mind you
can't organize your mind people who have
a hard time structuring their thinking
and behavior often find this very useful
which is to you know take out a journal
or a piece of paper again this is is
just for you it's important that you
realize and really make sure that you're
the only person that's going to see
these notes because a lot of people get
into self-monitoring when they're doing
their journaling they're thinking about
well how's this going to look is my
handwriting okay how's my punctuation
what are people going to think is this
going to be a good book or not a good
book listen none of this journaling that
we're referring to is about your book or
your autobiography this is really just
for you this is an exploration of
yourself that's designed to help you
enhance your concept that is your
understanding of self and indeed
translates to better confidence better
understanding of your goals and
aspirations better understanding of your
unhealthy patterns and defenses and on
and on and so again the two styles of
journaling are free association so where
you literally just write down any that
comes to mind or that you feel like
writing down within a given period of
time for most people 10 minutes is ample
time to do that for some people five
will be enough and for some who have the
time maybe 30 30 minutes but for me and
I think for most people out there
anywhere from 5 to 10 minutes of this
data dump free association you know it
could be your anxieties what you're
thinking about what you're anxious about
really could be about anything that
comes to mind and this free association
process can be very useful for clearing
out the Clutter so to speak the other
style of journaling that's equally
useful but for different reasons is
structure journaling to have a goal for
a given entry on a given day and again
this could be done in the morning
afternoon or night and the idea would be
that you would set an intention and by
intention I mean a specific topic that
you're going to restrict your writing to
and that writing should be about self in
particular goals and aspirations what
you've wanted in the past yes but also
what you want at present what you might
want in the future for yourself these
could of course be material things but
in general this is more about
aspirations of things that you would
like like to accomplish or generate and
the key word there is generate and if
you listen to the four episode series
with Dr kti he talked about three drives
that exist in all of us these three
drives are the aggressive Drive the
pleasure drive and the generative drive
and we don't need to go into a lengthy
description about these drives right now
if you're curious about them and what
they represent and uh how they can be in
balance or out of balance and how that
serves us or doesn't serve us please
check out that four episode series with
Dr because he goes into that in a fair
amount of detail and also in an
actionable way but the key thing here is
that we're generative you know one of
the things that I asked Dr kti at the
outset and throughout the entire series
was you know what is mental health you
know we talk about physical health and
we have some idea of what that
represents you know healthy blood
pressure the ability to do certain forms
of physical movement cognitive abilities
you know I asked him how can we Define
mental health and his answer was very
straightforward and very powerful he
said said what we all need to Aspire to
is to be in states that is in the verb
actions of agency and gratitude for as
much of our Waking Life as possible now
that sounds great right a sense of
agency the ability to exert influence
over our internal State and affect the
world around us in positive ways
positive relationships reach our goals
as well as gratitude being grateful for
the opportunities that we've been
afforded even grateful perhaps for some
of the challenges that we've been
afforded or that uh were selected for us
that we had no control over
and carrying that agency and gratitude
forward because it gives rise to a sense
of Peace contentment and Delight so all
of that sounds wonderful right be in
agency and gratitude as a verb States
experience peace contentment and Delight
but Dr kti acknowledged and we spent a
good amount of time discussing the fact
that doesn't happen just because we
decide we want to in fact agency and
gratitude peace contentment and Delight
geyser up from a whole set of other
processes that we have to engage in on a
regular basis and that really gets us
back to those three drives he talked
about how people tend to have more or
less aggressive drive not just
aggression in terms of violence although
some people do have that but in terms of
their determination and their sort of
Leaning into friction even seeking out a
friction people are on a Continuum with
respect to the aggressive drive he also
talked about the pleasure drive and the
fact that people are on a Continuum of
the desire for pleasure to either be a
hedonist or somebody who really avoids
pleasure and kind of restricts pleasure
from oneself and again that these things
can slide around depending on our life
circumstances our age Etc but that it's
very important that we have a sense of
where we are on that Continuum of an
aggressive drive and a pleasure drive
and that and here's the most important
thing that our aggressive drive and
pleasure Drive never outsize our
generative drive and that engaging our
generative Drive is really the Hallmark
of mental health that leads to that
sense of agency and gratitude peace
contentment and delight and he defined
the generative Drive in the following
way he said the generative Drive is our
desire to create build and contribute to
the world in meaningful ways and
appreciate the process to get there it
is the core feature of our mental health
so if you want to learn more about the
various drives and how they interact and
how to access more generative drive
again that's all contained in the four
episode series with Dr Ki but taking us
back to the tools and takeaways from
that four episode series the process of
journaling in free association mode or
the process of journaling in a conscious
structured way is really about trying to
access the generative drive and to build
up that generative drive and one of the
key things about conscious journaling is
that it affords us the opportunity in a
way that's not going to be seen by
anybody else to really think about what
our goals and aspirations are now you
might say you know I can't even think
about my goals and aspirations I don't I
don't know know what I want well that's
fine then you should Journal about that
however most people have some sense of
what they would like but most people are
simply not comfortable with writing
those things out or even thinking about
them and if you reflect on that how
could it ever be that you would achieve
those goals and aspirations if you're
not even feeling comfortable enough to
think about them or write about them and
so the process of thinking about and
writing about your goals and aspirations
is perhaps one of the key first steps
towards being able to actualize those
goals and aspirations and for some
people this might be very easy to do you
can simply write down say I want to you
know be married by this age and I want
to you know make x amount of money and I
want to live here or there and certainly
those sorts of goals and aspirations are
perfectly valid for this type of
exercise but so are the sorts of goals
and aspirations that relate to feeling
States like yeah I would like to feel
part of a community I would like to feel
like an active contributor to a
community and then the essential thing
is to really flesh out out the detail
around those goals and aspirations you
know what size Community uh where do you
see yourself fitting into this community
are you doing this alongside other
people or by yourself in other words to
really get comfortable thinking about
what your goals and aspirations are
again completely from the perspective of
self and that you are going to be the
only person to see this particular
document now I will be the first to
admit that the exercise that I just
described not the free association
journaling but the structured journaling
of goals and aspirations I and many
people find to be difficult to initiate
difficult to initiate because there
seems to be a bit of internal anxiety
and friction around doing it there seems
to be something that keeps many not all
but many people from feeling as if they
are even allowed to think about their
goals and aspirations because many
people default to well then you know
I'll just be disappointed because it's
not going to work out I don't want to
think about what I want because then
I'll just be more disappointed and that
particular frame of mind was actually
discussed in the series with Dr Cony and
he convinced me and he's the expert that
the opposite is actually true when we
are able to overcome some of our anxiety
and really think about in a dedicated
way what we would like to create for
ourselves in our lives both present and
future and keeping in mind our events of
past because we always carry that life
narrative forward then we are in a far
better place to actualize those goals
and aspirations and he explained a
variety of reasons why that's the case
and his clinical observations and some
of the are observations that really
support that statement so I highly
encourage you to think about embracing a
process of journaling again you don't
have to do this every day the journaling
and the dream analysis take a little bit
more time but they are oh so valuable
for better understanding one's
self-concept and they really thread
forward into real everyday actions that
can positively enrich your mood and
mental health now any description of
science-based tools for mood and mental
health would be incomplete without
including some tools related to
processing of traumas
now the processing of traumas is
something that especially in the case of
major traumas or repeated traumas really
should be carried out in concert with a
expert trained clinician that is a
psychologist or psychiatrist who's
trained in helping people work through
traumas however even if you're working
with somebody who's expert in processing
trauma there are specific tools that you
can use on your own to accelerate that
process and for people who are working
through what are sometimes called more
minor traumas these are sometimes called
Big tea big traumas and little te little
traumas however you know that
nomenclature doesn't take into account
the fact that you know most of us can
probably tell what the big traumas are
for ourselves and for others but
sometimes it's hard to tell whether or
not those small traumas the little tea
traumas actually are big te traumas so
you know this is one of the major
reasons why working with a licensed
professional is really going to be
advantageous and in many cases necessary
to work through trauma that said the
self directed protocols for working
through trauma have a lot to do with how
we think about but more importantly at
times how we talk about those traumas
and Dr Paul kti talked about this not so
much in the four episode series with us
but in a particular podcast episode that
he did with Dr Peter Atia who some of
you are perhaps familiar with for his
incredible podcast the drive but also
for his excellent book outlive which
deals with health span and lifespan or
longevity now in that particular
conversation with Dr Ki and Dr AA Dr kti
emphasized the fact that one of the ways
that we hold ourselves back and indeed
can exacerbate the negative consequences
of trauma are the ways in which we
modify our language to describe those
traumas and what he said which is so
important is that often times we don't
allow ourselves to use language that's
as big as is necessary to explain that
trauma and the impact of that that
trauma on us and on others in fact many
people start to you know relegate their
language to more passible in a given
sentence or passible in a given
conversation now what we're not talking
about here is the idea that okay you
know screaming at somebody else about
your trauma or using a lot of
four-letter words is necessarily the
best way to process that trauma verbally
however we are talking about allowing
oneself either in spoken form or in
written form to really allow the
magnitude of a given trauma to be
expressed with a fair degree of
intensity and language that can capture
at least some of what that trauma
represented for us or for others now as
Dr kti pointed out all too often we do
the opposite what ends up happening is
people will experience some sort of
trauma either major or minor maybe
single or repeated trauma and rather
than being comfortable talking about it
rather than using language that captures
at least some of the magnitude of that
trauma for them people start to talk
about that trauma less frequently they
start to distract themselves to think
about other things instead of talking
about or thinking about that trauma and
what happens is that trauma Roots into
our unconscious mind and starts to
impact Us in negative ways now those
negative ways include increases in
anxiety disruptions in sleep in fact one
of the common ways in which trauma
manifests in disruptions in sleep by way
of rooting our unconscious is that
people will wake up at 2:30 or 3:00 in
the morning let's just say after several
hours of being asleep and immediately
they're thinking about that thing that
happened and they're upset about it the
idea is that when we push those traumas
down when we don't talk about them with
people that we trust when we don't have
a way to consciously process those
traumas using language that at least
partially matches the magnitude of the
impact of those traumas for us well then
those traumas impact our unconscious
mind in ways that lead our unconscious
mind to literally wake us up in the
middle of the night and remind us of
that thing it's as if it's being thrown
back in our face over and over also
sometimes traumas will root their way
down into our unconscious and then they
will resurface in the mode of compulsive
or obsessive thinking about that thing
or perhaps other things again the
unconscious mind has a interesting and
complicated number of different ways
that it defends us the ways that it you
know can create denial distraction that
we might get hyperfocused on work as a
way to not think about the trauma or
hyper focused on some details in our
environment and just really trying to
focus on that because it's much easier
to process and handle that than these
traumas you know again the processing of
trauma is a whole landscape into itself
that actually was um beautifully
described in terms of how it arises
within us and how to process traumas in
a really structured way in a just
fabulous book that was written by Dr Ki
called The Invisible epidemic how trauma
works and how we can heal from it and in
that book Dr Ki explains a number of
different ways that we can do
self-directed work as well as work with
licensed professionals to process
traumas and help us move through those
traumas so that they are not negatively
impacting us going forward so I really
encourage anyone that's trying to
process traumas from the past and or
present to check out Dr kti's book
because it's a spectacular resource but
in terms of the tools related to
processing trauma that we're talking
about right now I think this point about
really making sure that we allow
ourselves to verbally process and
emotionally process that trauma in a way
that there's room for using language
that captures some of the magnitude of
that trauma and how it impacted us and
others is going to be very important
because otherwise what ends up happening
is that we tend to adopt feelings of
guilt and shame around those traumas
simply by not talking about them by
having them go Inward and then they
start to negatively impact our
unconscious mind and then our
unconscious mind tries to throw them up
to the surface for our conscious mind to
recognize by waking us up from sleep and
in some cases by leveraging those
unhealthy defenses things like denial
things like you know the overindulgence
in alcohol overindulgence of drugs ways
to distract ourselves as well as
projection and sublimation and the other
types of defenses that Dr kti talked
about in the four episode series again
those defenses are not necessarily good
or bad it depends on the circumstances
the unconscious mind is not trying to
harm us your unconscious mind is part of
you it is you but of course it is you
acting in concert with your conscious
mind and so really the tools and
protocols from the four episode series
with Dr Ki are aimed at helping you feel
and access more sense of agency and
gratitude on a regular basis more peace
contentment and delight and doing so by
touching into those different drives
understanding what they are the
aggressive Drive the pleasure drive and
really making sure that your generative
drive again I love this description of
the generative drive so much so that I'm
going to read it again because this is
really what it means to be mentally
healthy again the generative Drive is
our desire to create build and
contribute to the world in a meaningful
way and appreciate the process to get
there it is the core feature of our
mental health so being able to access
that generative drive on a regular basis
is is really what this thing that we
call mental health is all about and the
tools that I just described of course
can be combined with in any number of
different ways with the tools that I
described glean largely from the episode
with Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett and so what
you now have is a kit of tools and
protocols for improving mood and mental
health some of which are grounded in
that core six the you know first
principles of self-care are always going
to be getting your physiology right so
that your psychology can be right as
well well of course you want to
emphasize tools and protocols that build
up your psychological processes and
concept of self that's what the tools
from the Conti series that we just
described are all about and then the
tools from the episode with Dr Lisa
Feldman Barrett sort of bridge the two
because she talked about both the
physiological and the psychological
tools that really represent ways to
enhance our mood and mental health and
so by threading these three things
together I believe it really arms us
with the greatest degree of optimism and
capacity to take control of this thing
that we call our mood and emotions and
to of course allow ourselves to feel the
negative things we need to feel but then
process them in healthy ways and to
exist as much as is reasonably possible
in generally optimistic upbeat states
that allow us to engage our generative
drive and although we covered a lot of
tools during this episode again I want
to emphasize that the idea isn't to
necessarily do all of them all at once
maybe just pick one or two and start to
implement them on a regular basis basis
and by implementing those there's no
reason to think that you would be
significantly eating into your other
demands on your time because ultimately
the whole purpose of having elevated
mood and mental health is so that you
can have better relationship to yourself
and better relationship to others and to
the world around you if you're learning
from and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zeroc cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a festar review please check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast if
you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guests that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
hubman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments not so much on today's
episode but on many previous episodes of
The hubman Lab podcast we discussed
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep hormone
support and focus to learn more about
the supplements discussed on the hubman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentus
spelled o us so that's live mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram X formerly known as Twitter
threads LinkedIn and Facebook and on all
those platforms I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content on the
huberman Lab podcast so again it's
hubman lab on all social media platforms
if you haven't already subscribed to the
hubman Lab podcast monthly neural
network newsletter the neural network
newsletter is a completely zeroc cost
newsletter that includes summaries of
podcast episodes as well as toolkits
toolkits are brief PDFs that describe in
bullet point Form Tools for for instance
enhancing sleep neuroplasticity
deliberate cold exposure deliberate heat
exposure Fitness dopamine regulation and
much more to sign up for the hubman Lab
podcast neural network newsletter simply
go to huberman lab.com
go to the menu tab scroll down to
newsletter and put in your email we do
not share your email with anybody thank
you once again for joining me for
today's discussion all about
science-based tools for enhancing mood
and mental health and last but certainly
not least thank you for your interest in
[Music]
science